in your own words uh describe quantum
theory
oh Jesus nope I'm gonna skip this
[Music]
episode I'm sorry Cassie
congratulations on the film this is your
second Marvel project after Loki is
there a difference in filming like a
Disney plus series versus an MCU movie I
don't know yet
I don't know yet I experienced it but it
was also the processes were quite
different one as you know or as you may
or may not know when I shot Loki's Loki
season one that's one scene you know and
I guess the background of that is it was
one scene we shot it for and it was all
in one room I only had two scene
partners and it was it we to me it felt
more like theater but the Precision and
the focus and all that was there right
we also had a I won't get in the details
but the same lady who shot that TV show
was the same wonderful cinematographer
that shot uh Black Panther it's all kind
of the same vibration but then you have
Kang in quantumania where I'm there from
the beginning to end and that process
you know where I'm doing multiple things
with that same yeah it was different it
was different but it was also different
I think in a different country and on
stuff you know
um no it's the same you know it's
ultimately it's the same like my
Approach is the same and the best thing
to do you know as far as quality control
is just you know keep your stuff
together you know I mean and um the the
heads and the collaborators that you
know both of these Studios for both of
these projects were malleable you know
to that so it's all the same thing so
you were the mcu's biggest like Baddie
now after Thanos
um in a fight no Gauntlet Thanos versus
King who will kick who's ass I'm like I
don't want to start no problems but I
think it I think it would just be a hard
goal for Thanos I think it just would be
tough for him and even if you beat Kane
could he beat the other variants you
know there's no the thing about Kang and
why you can't beat Kang let me just make
sure this is right before
we break the internet you can't break
Kang because he he doesn't quit you
can't that's why you can't beat him he
has no quit if you were to quote unquote
defeat him there's another one so that
how do you beat Something That Never
Ends yeah now everybody will figure it
out but yeah yeah no right now not right
not right now not today no out of all
the Marvel movies Ant-Man is perhaps
like one of the most sciency ones are
you good at signs at all uh I'm gonna
say yes but now I'm nervous to say that
but yeah yeah I'm good at science that
science is about biology physics
chemistry okay because I have a pop quiz
for you uh Jonathan Michael
um
the teacher and we popped out uh in your
own words uh describe quantum theory
oh Jesus nope I'm gonna skip that
because because I don't know well enough
to make it concise
okay and I'll spin up I'll spin up all
your time I won't I'll get it right I
might get it wrong but I would spend too
much time
and then we wouldn't have another
question yeah back to me another time
yeah I'm sure there's a very concise
like this is what it is I don't have
that so maybe I don't know it as well as
I think I do now my last question worked
alongside three of like the sexiest man
of the MCU um besides yourself of course
uh Paul Rush
Paul Wright Tom Hiddleston and Michael B
Jordan for Crete 3 which is really fun
too
um who do you enjoy working with the
most wait you forgot one you just elbow
oh my God yeah yeah he's over well what
about these sexy men are you asking what
do you want to know uh could you enjoy
working with the most well in all their
sexy Glory I would have I don't know I
have a very different relationship with
all of them like Idris and I are I mean
we're like brothers he's like my big
brother right we're going a day apart
Tom and I are like pen pals and like
poetry buddies and like talk about
cheats and Shakespeare and and all these
things and Michael B Jordan is my cut
man and probably currently my best
friend and Paul Rudd right now is like
my road dog we're like Radiohead out
here I won't tell you who's Tom York but
you know like we're just gorgeous you
know we're like SNL buddies you know I
have fun with all four of them and I'm
just happy that all four of these
incredibly talented uh and attractive
men are in my life see I would have
burnt it all up with this Quantum
Quantum stuff yeah all right thank you
so much that's all the time I have with
you today
[Music]
foreign